you heard recently that psilocybin
mushrooms were supposed to be
decriminalized in Denver apparently it's
not decriminalized it's just lower on
priority for cops so it's still illegal
to do so it's an option can I give you a
free pass they're so busy that what you
didn't [ __ ] mushrooms but it is
important to know that you can't just
walk around and have mushrooms what if
they're portobello mushroom Oh
psilocybin mushrooms magic mushrooms
where I'm not much I'm sorry I totally
missed our you're on you know there's
there's news like oh that Denver
decriminalize the possession or whatever
use of psilocybin mushrooms that's not
necessarily true they're still illegal
it's just if you have a small amount and
you're a cop and you have other like
other drugs I get to worry about it's up
to the cop to be like whether or not he
wants to arrest you for it but it is
illegal okay hmm
I saw it from Tim Ferriss disposers had
dinner with Tim talk to him a lot about
that stuff he didn't tell you that no we
didn't talk about the GAO said that
stops talking about psychedelics and how
many he sees really I think he might
write a book about it eventually I don't
know if I had been I would assume he
writes a book about it
yeah it's a it's a really interesting
isn't really do talk about it yeah he's
an dude I want to go down I want to go
down that rabbit hole a little bit you
do ever since he ain't too old for that
ever since damn t know ever since DMT
I'm into psychedelics mom not know I'm
interested in where it takes what are
you we're were you gonna go I don't know
it's the same idea as meditation where
am I gonna go I think that there are
things I'm interested in exploring my
subconscious exploring with what goes on
I think there's something there
actually there's so many SmartKey
whenever well there I will but there are
so many smart people I know that are
doing this true and I know that doesn't
necessarily mean that that but I I'm
curious about the I I I'm I just want to
see what the fuss is about maybe that's
what it is because I'm getting we did D
I'm getting very into meditation yeah
and I thought that was badass
was a worldly experience to open up your
eyes no no no are you looking for a
bigger meaning of life and all that
not really I I'm curious about my own
subconscious but I'm not I don't think
there I don't think
grits will be revealed and I like your
question I like your question and I like
your skepticism because I have it - do
you know anyone who's just no go on
please say it because it's an
interesting conversation in other words
I know what you're saying like like is
Tony Robbins doing psychedelics well was
Einstein was do you think Steph Curry's
into mushrooms I mean see I like you
guys Bron James or Steve Steve Jobs
dislike you does Neil deGrasse Tyson or
there are a lot of people including
great Yogi's and meditation
contemplative athletes that aren't doing
it yeah but I - I guess it may be a
different type of mindset because
there's like drogon super super
successful but woody but regardless
correct but he's always been that guy I
think the question you're asking is why
are a deeper understanding one gains
from doing psychedelic my arm on the
side right now right now of saying
probably not well people girl you open
your mind yeah I'm I'm hoping I if that
if you want to do it I don't that's fine
I just don't you don't feel you I don't
know I don't feel it you don't feel that
there's a there there ok did DMT and I
was in like oh my god it's so clear to
me now I got your friend go to Mexico
doing a bunch of shrooms and he's trying
to fight you know he's like you I want
to give me direction oh my god if you're
looking for shrink for Direction brother
I don't a problem I don't know man but
you know what let's say he goes there
and maybe that's for him it works walk
yeah dude do all the shrooms you want
yeah I just thought like if my son came
to me at 18 was like dad I don't know
what to do I'm so lost then she just
saved my money go to Mexico do a bunch
of shrooms I'm like well that's probably
not the smartest choice done but maybe
for this dude he's older it's gonna work
I don't know
yeah be I'm skeptical I'm and I think
being skeptical about psychedelics is
smart because I am - no psycho now go
down that rabbit hole because I want to
I just want to see what's up I want to
see if there's I did have a bit of a
life-changing experience
mushrooms when I was 24 now I was
younger
I'm 52 now kind of have a good sense of
who I am I have a good sense of what's
important the only good thing with
mushrooms to it like can't OD on them so
it's not you can get hurt right you know
you end up like Artie Lange and I am
[ __ ] well that's different
psychedelic sin and opiates for example
or yeah I think if you're doing a get
controlled environment people know what
they're doing it could be fun yeah I
can't express enough ABS zero interest
you can OD and die but they said that
some people they're the worry their
brains are wired they don't come back
from something that's the scary thing
for me so yeah so it's often mushrooms
I'll do some [ __ ] shrooms hey you
just said you didn't they said you're
not going to I'll do some shrooms and
[ __ ] everybody in here not you cat what
you to what leave Kat out of this I
appreciate what we hold and you and I
look like giant vaginas and asses and he
was just like oh I remember I was a kid
there's a rumor going around this guy
did acid or PCP I think was asked my sir
I thought his skin was an orange and
started PFP that story I think it's fake
I think a lot of that's a fake but I
dunno scared me enough though where it
work does it not doing PI do know that
there was a guy who they [ __ ] with and
I have maybe I know the guy he was kind
of a dick he did a bunch of acid somehow
he ended up in the bathtub and they
should take a bath it'll it'll help you
he got in the bathtub and I started to
feel like he was a piece of chicken in
soup and then everybody was around I
mean because you guys are trying to make
soup out of me no legit can and then my
the guys the people were scumbags and
started cutting carrots
it's celery and then seasoning in a
bathtub and he's like yeah can we show
and he was freaking Howard likely to do
that is somebody yeah so yeah so they
turned him into soup do you guys ever
mess with uh you don't look like you've
ever done any drugs yet no nothing I
mean I used to smoke weed but not very
much mmm gin I did him know I'm the
first time I tried ecstasy I did three
tabs in one night I had no idea
you're not supposed to do that much and
what happens it they were like [ __ ]
everybody
they're like it wears off after like two
or three hours we're at a rave so I was
like it already wore off good no felt
amazing but the next week or so I wasn't
myself to happen I was freaking out
suicidal
yeah no we're not suicide about like
yeah your serotonin serotonin levels
drop you just use ignition yeah you're
definitely Saturday down there I got
sick I got it really I got a really bad
cold right after I was just I guess I
get depressed I was like oh yeah you did
one I'm probably never killing Wow just
kidding personnel prisons why'd you make
them Brazil I don't know there's no
Brazilians in [ __ ] Vegas
wait misery and prostitute never
happened is funny
can you imagine Brazilian exhale oh yeah
I'm trying to get my Brazilian accent
you have to try this I did ecstasy it's
good gonna get you high although
Jamaican no jamia ma if you would if you
are on no it's this image I this ecstasy
where did you get it right down by the
Beach Boys tear off your face boy you
have a good time suck your dry boys well
they're pros dude